The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ALIA MARTIN: I'm going
to be talking today
about how infants and
kids start to develop
an understanding
of communication
and why this is an important
topic for understanding
human intelligence.
So what is communication?
So really, basically,
communication
is a transfer or
exchange of information.
And importantly, in
human communication,
this isn't just any
kind of information,
but it's specifically the
kind of information that's
in our heads and in our minds.
So for example, there's
information in my head
right now that I'm going
to be transferring to you
over the course of this talk.
And the reason we need
communication to do this
and that we use it all
the time is obviously
that everyone has
minds of their own
and that we don't have access
to the mental states of others.
And we can't automatically
transfer our own mental states
to theirs without some means
of making those mental states
observable in the form of
communicating with them.
So people are both
cognitive beings--
we have to sort of navigate the
thoughts in our heads and try
to figure out the thoughts
that are in other's heads--
but we're also social beings.
We really benefit
from gaining access
to the thoughts in
the minds of others
and giving them access
to our own thoughts.
So for example, for cooperation,
competition, learning,
and teaching, and all the
kinds of social interactions
we do with each
other, we have to be
able to share the contents
of our mental states.
And it's this sort of joint,
both cognitive and social
nature of communication
that I think
makes it especially
important for understanding
the development of
human intelligence.
It sort of crosscuts a lot
of these core knowledge
domains that Liz talked
about in her talk.
So human communication
requires reasoning
about others'
cognitive states, so
understanding what others'
beliefs, and desires,
and intentions are.
It also requires reasoning
about social interaction,
so understanding that typically
these kinds of thoughts,
and beliefs, and
intentions are not
shared among different people.
Everyone has their own
that are unobservable
and housed in their own heads.
But in the context
of a particular kind
of social interaction,
these people
can intentionally share their
thoughts with each other.
And communication often
involves reasoning
about a third thing, which
is language or communicative
signals outside of
language as well.
And so I'm going to back
to this point at the end,
but all these types
of reasoning are
going to come up in the studies
about infant communication
that I describe in the talk.
And so Liz talked about
how infants start out
with these coherent, separate,
principle, and core knowledge
systems that contain some
limited representations
for reasoning about the world,
and which kind of come together
around the end of
the first year.
So if we want to figure out
how to build a model of how
social cognitive
development works,
we're going to need to
understand how an infant starts
to figure out, using
the core knowledge
that they have early in life,
the components of communication
and also how these components
come together so that infants
can build a more complex
causal model of communication
like adults have.
So this is just to
illustrate the points
I'm making about the
communicative situation.
So in any given
communicative situation,
we can't just think about
the words that are being said
or what we're hearing.
We need to think about it in
this broader context of having
a communicator or maybe multiple
communicators, an addressee
or an audience, and also the
things that the communicator is
saying in the
broader context that
allow us to figure
out what's going on
in this social interaction.
So it really requires
understanding
that the communicator's
mental states are
being transferred
in this causal way
to the mind of the addressee.
So I'm going to structure
the talk in terms
of some important insights
from the philosophy
of human language
and communication
that I think have
really guided the way
researchers in the
last, say, 50 years have
been thinking about
the development
of human communication as well.
So I'm going to broadly
illustrate the three points
that I'm taking from each,
and then I'll expand on them
in each section.
So the first
insight that I think
is really important
for understanding
how we think about communication
comes from John Austin, who
brought up the important point.
So before Austin,
people tended to think
about language or study language
a lot in terms of language
itself, and the semantics, and
syntax, and just the language
signal.
But Austin pointed out
that language is actually
not just about the content,
but it's also an action.
It's actually something that we
use, and we do things with it,
in the same way that we do
things and accomplish things
in the world using other kinds
of actions that we engage in.
So Austin sort of brought up
this important distinction
that language is not
just about the content.
So to illustrate
with an example,
in this communicative
interaction,
there's language here.
This person is saying,
is there any salt?
And Austin analyzed
this in terms
of not only what
the words meant,
but in terms of three
layers of intentionality.
So in this simple
interaction, he pointed out
that there's a locutionary act,
or the meaning of the sentence,
which is that there's
a question being asked
about the presence of
salt. But that there's
actually something
else going on here
as well, which is that there's
an illocutionary action, which
is what he considers to be
the intention underlying
the action, which is
to request the salt.
So if you actually just
read this sentence,
it's kind of under-determined.
It's not necessarily
obvious that this person's
asking the other person at
this table to pass the salt.
But if you take it
within the broader
context of the interaction,
you can understand
that what's really going on here
is not just a sentence being
produced, but rather one
individual requesting something
from another, who is then
supposed to understand
the request, and in the
third layer of analysis,
cause the addressee
to provide the salt.
So the idea is that there are
these multiple things going on
in the context of a
communicative interaction
involving language that
go beyond the words that
are actually being spoken here.
And so if you're an infant, just
like in philosophy of language,
the focus in infant
cognitive development--
also for a long
time, and still is,
we still need to
understand these things--
was on understanding
how infants learn words,
or how infants figure out
the meaning of language,
and how it relates to
objects in the environment,
and later, to the
abstract concepts
that language indicates.
But importantly, understanding
communication for an infant
is going to be more than
about just figuring out
the meaning of these words.
And so following the
philosophical tradition
of people like
Austin, who introduced
the study of
pragmatics to language,
developmental
psychologists as well
started thinking about the
importance of recognizing
communication as this
broader action in its context
for understanding how
infants come to be good
communicators themselves.
So if communication involves
this whole context of action
and interaction between
people, if you're
a baby who's in the
business of understanding
the social world, the
agent world, and the world
of language, you're going to
be well-served by developing
an ability to identify these
kinds of communicative actions
or situations and
their components,
and to begin to
understand how they work.
So how do infants
start to figure out
when communication is going
on in the world around them,
rather than just identifying
words and associating them
with objects?
So actually, there's
a lot of evidence
that infants are
identifying key features
of communicative situations
really early in life.
So from the time they're
born, newborn human infants
prefer listening to
speech over other sounds.
So the typical
method that's used
to measure the preference
of an infant who's
only one to four
days old is to have
them suck on a pacifier
that's connected
to a machine that detects how
strongly infants are sucking.
And then the sucking is
used as a measure of infants
arousal upon hearing
a particular sound
or being exposed to a
particular stimulus.
And so what researchers found
is that if you have infants suck
on this pacifier while
listening to speech
sounds and nonspeech
sounds in alternation,
nonspeech sounds being
sine wave-produced sounds
that are very similar to
speech in their features.
If you listen to it, it has
the prosodic contours of speech
and sounds a lot like it,
but it's not actually speech.
You can't actually
parse any words from it.
Infants showed a
preference for listening
to speech over nonspeech,
or more arousal
when they listened to speech.
So they maintained
their arousal for speech
over the course
of the experiment,
but for nonspeech, it declined.
And so extremely
early in life, infants
seem to have this bias
for paying attention
to the primary communicative
signal of our species, that is,
human speech.
Quite early in life
as well, infants
recognize some of the important
features of the social context
surrounding speech,
so getting more
into the domain of the important
features for communication.
So by six months,
infants seem to recognize
that speech is
human-produced, or at least
associate speech
with other humans,
and also human-directed.
So in one study, infants
saw pictures of human faces
or faces of monkeys, and
they heard different sounds.
So they either heard--
oh, it seems like the sound
is not on, but that's OK.
So they either-- oops.
So they either heard a
speech sound in a language
they never heard before
repeating itself,
or they heard a monkey call.
And infants in one trial either
saw-- so in the first trial,
say, they'd see the
human face, and then they
could listen repeatedly
to a speech sound
until they looked
away for two seconds.
And then they would
see a monkey face,
and then they would hear either
a speech sound or a monkey
sound and be able to
look at this image
while listening to that
sound until they looked away
for two seconds.
And so they got all
possible combinations.
Sometimes they saw a human
face and listened to speech.
Sometimes they saw a
human face and listened
to the monkey sounds.
And sometimes they
saw the monkey face
and listened to either human
speech or the monkey sound.
And the question was
whether infants actually
could match speech
sounds to humans
and recognize that they should
be produced by the human rather
than the monkey.
And that's what they found.
So you can see that when
infants heard speech,
they were much more
likely to look at the--
yeah, they were looking at the
human when they heard speech,
and then they were
looking at the monkey
when they heard
the monkey calls.
Similarly, infants seem to
understand by six months
that speech is directed
at other humans.
So when they saw
a person talking
behind a barrier
versus acting, so
swiping with her hand
behind a barrier,
and then the
barrier was revealed
to reveal either a
person or an object,
infants looked longer for
the speaking familiarization
when they saw that
there had been
an object behind the
barrier than a person,
suggesting that
they expected speech
to be directed toward
another person.
And in contrast, when they
saw the person swiping,
they looked much longer
when they saw a person
behind the barrier
because typically, we
don't swipe at people.
We tend to speak to them.
So this suggests that
infants understand
some of the features
of the context
in which human
communication is produced.
Importantly, infants
do still seem
to be developing this ability
over the first year of life
because it's not until 10
months that they expect
mutual gaze between
speakers, which
tends to be an important
part of understanding
the social context
of communication.
So in this study, infants saw
two people facing each other.
This is just one of the
experiments from the study.
But you can see that they
saw the two people looking
at each other and
speaking to each other,
or the two people looking apart
and speaking to each other.
Infants at nine months
didn't differentiate
between these at all.
So at nine months,
they didn't necessarily
think that the people were
going to look at each other
when they were speaking.
But at 10 months,
you can see here
that infants looked longer
for the averted gaze
than for the mutual gaze.
So infants seem to
be able to recognize
when a communicative context
is going on early in life.
But we don't necessarily
know from these studies
whether they really understand
that communication is happening
or whether they're
just detecting
some important features of
communicative interactions
that might help them to glom
onto communication so that they
can eventually develop
an ability to figure out
what's going on within the
communicative interaction
themselves.
So, so far in the studies
that I've mentioned,
there's nothing cognitive here.
There's nothing
really about infants
having to understand the
intentions or the mental states
of the speaker going into
the mind of the addressee,
like I was talking about before.
So a question I've
explored in my research
is whether infants recognize
that when these features are
in place, when you have a
communicative signal, which
is something they
recognize, when
you have a communicator
and addressee who
are socially engaged
with each other,
do infants recognize that
communication can actually lead
to the transfer of information?
So do infants understand
that speech, using speech,
because this is something
that infants seem to recognize
as a signal that's important
in communicative context,
can transfer information
between individuals?
So we can use speech to
communicate with each other
about what we're interested in.
So if I'm observing
this interaction
between a communicator
and an addressee,
I can infer that if the
communicator says, the cup,
and there's only
one cup present,
the addressee's
probably going to be
able to figure out what it is
that the communicator wants.
And I can figure this out even
from a third party perspective.
And I can also understand
that other kinds of sounds,
like perhaps a positive
emotional vocalization,
are not going to be as
effective in communicating
to the addressee what the
communicator is interested in.
So speech and also
other communicative
signals as well that can specify
this sort of information,
perhaps like pointing or
particular kinds of gestures,
can transfer information from
one individual to another.
So speech is going to be more
effective for communicating
than other kinds of
noncommunicative actions.
And importantly, for the
purposes of this study,
you're not just going to know
that communicative information
transfer is going on because you
know what the word cup means,
even in a situation
where you're listening
to a foreign language,
and you have no idea what
the meaning of the words are.
Even in this
situation, you're going
to understand that some kind
of communicative information
transfer can happen.
So we've all had the experience
of being in a foreign country,
presumably, where
you're listening
to people speak to each other.
You can't necessarily
understand what they're saying,
but you know that information
transfer is happening.
So the interesting thing
about communicative actions
like speech is that
when we witness them,
we can know that people
are communicatively
sharing information,
even when we
don't know what information is
being communicated ourselves.
And this insight
suggests that maybe,
if you're an infant,
one really good way
to jump into the communicative
interactions around you
and start to understand
what's going on
is to be able to identify
when others are communicating.
And hearing the sounds
of speech exchanged
between two people in the
context of a social interaction
might be a really
good way to do this.
So an ability to figure out
when communication's going on
like this might provide infants
with this really powerful way
of being able to track the
information flow between two
other people's minds
and also to figure out,
based on their responses
to each other, what
the actual content of
the words might mean.
So we asked whether
infants recognize
that speech is communicative
at 12 months of age.
And so in the procedure
of this study,
infants were privy
to a third party
interaction between a
communicator and an addressee.
And the infant is always just
observing the interaction.
This is so that we can
isolate whether infants think
that certain communicative
vocalizations can transfer
information from the
communicator to an addressee,
even when the infant themselves
has all the information.
So the third party
nature of this procedure
is important here for seeing
whether infants really
are thinking about the fact that
thoughts are typically isolated
in particular people's minds,
but with communication, they
can be shared.
So infants in these studies
were given a violation
of expectation paradigm.
In this kind of experiment,
as many of you probably know,
infants are shown a story
through a series of scenes.
And then in the last
scene or series of scenes,
they're shown different
kinds of endings.
And we're interested in whether
infants are surprised or look
longer at some endings more
than they do at others.
So infants in these studies
were shown a live display
where they had an actor in
front of them in a stage.
First, they were familiarized
with this actor showing
a preference for an object
by picking it up and playing
with it repeatedly in
three separate scenes.
And so, as in the studies
by Amanda Woodward that Liz
already mentioned,
infants, by 12 months
and as early as three
months, will attribute a goal
to this person for reaching for
that particular target object.
So after being
familiarized to this,
infants saw an addressee,
who was a new person,
present in a totally
different part of the stage.
They had never seen
this person before,
and they'd never seen the
two people together before.
This person reached for
both objects in turn.
So first, she grabbed
this one, then this one,
and then this one, and
then this one again
to show that she didn't have a
preference between the objects
and could reach both of them.
Then in the test scene,
so this is the ending
that we showed infants, they
saw the two people together
for the first time, but
now the communicator
couldn't reach the objects
because only her face had
access to the stage.
But the addressee could
still reach them just fine.
At this point, the
crucial manipulation
was the vocalization
uttered by the communicator.
So she either produced a speech
sound, the nonsense word koba,
which infants had not
heard before, she produced
a coughing sound, so
something that would typically
be physiological and not
intentional or communicative
in any way, or an emotional
vocalization, so a sound
that perhaps could
convey information.
If I say, ooh, you might think
I'm interested in something,
I'm feeling positive,
but you won't necessarily
know what it is.
So this one's sort of in
the middle of the other two.
And then, infants saw
the addressee either
provide the target object
that the communicator had
reached for before or
the nontarget object.
And the question is, do
infants understand that speech
as a communicative signal,
do they have some expectation
that even though they've never
heard this particular speech
sound used before, that speech
can transfer information such
that the addressee will
now be able to select
the correct object?
Whereas nonspeech vocalizations
like coughing and emotional
vocalizations can't.
So if so, infants in
the speech condition
should look longer to nontarget
than target actions, responses,
finding these unexpected.
And infants in the
other two conditions
shouldn't differentiate
between the two.
And this is what we found.
So in the speech
condition, infants
are looking longer to
nontarget than target,
suggesting that they
understand that speech
can transfer information
about the communicator's goal.
But when the communicator
coughs or produces
an emotional
vocalization, infants
don't show these
same expectations.
So this is some initial
evidence that by 12 months,
infants not only recognize the
context in which communication
occurs and attend to
speech as a special signal
for communication, but
they also understand
that speech is something that's
able to transfer information
between two people.
So we also ran a few
control conditions
to rule out alternative
explanations for this.
So one important question is,
are infants really reasoning
about the addressee's access to
information in this situation?
So for example, in
the case where the--
if infants are really reasoning
with the addressee's access
to information, then in a case
where the communicator makes
a positive emotional
vocalization,
and the addressee has previous
information about what she's
interested in, so for
example, if she just
saw that the communicator
was trying to feed her child
or wanted a drink of
water, she might know now
that a positive emotional
vocalization is indicating
something like the cup.
So we set up a scenario
like this as well.
In this case, it's exactly the
same as the previous study,
except that the addressee
had visual access
to the communicators preference
during the familiarization
phase.
So now she knows what it is
that the communicator likes.
And this is important for making
sure the infants recognize
that something
like visual access
can provide the addressee
with information
about the
communicator's interest.
So now infants saw the same
addressee familiarization.
And then in the test,
they saw the communicator
produce the vocalization
ooh once again.
So now even though
ooh was not treated
as a communicative vocalization
in the previous studies,
if infants are reasoning
about the kinds of information
that the addressee
has access to,
they should now expect that
the addressee will provide
the target object
because she knows
from a previous scene what the
communicator was interested in.
So this is important also for
ruling out the possibility that
maybe just hearing these
noncommunicative vocalizations
surprises or confuses
infants or makes
them unable to reason
about the scenario anymore.
Here, they're getting a
noncommunicative vocalization,
but the addressee has
access to information.
And here, as in the
speech condition,
infants looked longer at
the nontarget outcome.
So this is just some evidence
that infants are really
thinking about the idea
that relevant sources
of information, such as a
communicative vocalization,
but also prior
visual access, can
give the addressee information
about the communicator's goal.
So they are reasoning
about information access.
Another important question
is, are they really thinking
about the source of
information, or do they
have-- so what's really the
mechanism behind what infants
are doing here?
Are they thinking something
like, when I hear speech,
everything will go
well, or the speaker
is going to get what she wants?
Or are they really thinking
about communication
in this causal way,
where the information has
to come from the
speaker and be delivered
to the listener in
order for it to work?
So to test for this, infants
saw another communicator
familiarization.
Here, the communicator is alone,
so they've never seen the two
people together before.
She reaches for
the target object.
Then they see the
addressee again.
And then in the test
scene, in this case,
the addressee is the one
who produces the speech.
So speech is present in
the scene as it was before,
but it's not being produced by
the communicator or the person
who showed a preference.
So if infants just
think that speech
leads to people obtaining
their goals or magical outcomes
happening, then they
should expect the addressee
to provide the
target here as well.
But if they understand that
they don't know anything
about the addressee, in
which case, this is not
really informative
about either object,
then they should look
equally to both outcomes.
And in fact, this is what
they do at 12 months.
So infants here don't
expect information
to be transferred
from one person
to another, unless the first
person who communicated
is the one who actually had
the information to provide.
So by 12 months, infants
seem to recognize
that speech is
communicative, and they
seem to have some of the
parts of a causal model
of communication.
They're not just
thinking about speech
as something that can
produce successful outcomes,
but as something
that can be used
to have information move from
the mind of one individual
to another.
So a 12-month-old
seemed to recognize
that speech is communicative.
But we really wanted
to get at the idea
that understanding that
speech is communicative
might be something
that drives and guides
word learning and language
acquisition, rather
than something that
is as a result.
So what a 12-month-old
could be doing in this study
is hearing the word koba,
associating it with the object
that the communicator
had reached for,
and then thinking, OK,
that one's the koba,
so that's what the
addressee should reach for.
But in these studies, we were
interested in whether infants
at an even younger age,
who would be very, very
unlikely to be associating
the word with the object
or learning a label for
the object over the course
of the study, would
also recognize
that speech can transfer
information about one person
to another person.
And so for this reason,
we tested 6-month-olds,
because 6-month-olds
understand only some very, very
common words in
their environment
and will look to
the right object
when they hear the label for it.
But these are very,
very limited words,
and there's no
evidence for learning
a word in a single
trial, which is what they
would have to do in this study.
They would have to hear
koba, and then think back
to what the communicator
had reached for,
and really learn that word over
the course of the study, which
we have no evidence that
a 6-month-old can do.
So the goal of looking
at this age group
was to see whether
infants might have
a more abstract understanding
of the idea that when speech
is produced, information can
be transferred from one person
to another, even
when they themselves
don't know what
that information--
or what the link between
the word and the object.
So a 6-month-old
saw the same scenes.
We gave them the speech
versus cough contrast.
And they look the same as
the 12-month-olds here.
So you can see that
in the speech case,
they're looking longer
for the nontarget outcome.
And in the cough
case, they're looking
longer for the target outcome.
And so we haven't done all of
the same control conditions
as with the 12-month-olds here.
So I think there's a lot of
room for questions about how
a 6-month-old's understanding
of communication
in this causal way more
limited than the understanding
of 12-month-olds.
Would a six-month-old
think that if speech
was produced by a loudspeaker
or by the addressee,
that the communicator would
still get the right object?
So there are a lot of
open questions about--
these basic questions about
how infants' understanding
of communicative information
transfer starts out.
So these experiments
suggest that by six months,
infants seem to understand
that speech is communicative,
in addition to the other
studies that suggest
they understand
some of the features
of communicative interactions.
They recognize that it
transfers information
from one person to another.
And I'd like to
argue that this might
be something that provides
a mechanism for language
and knowledge acquisition,
so sort of guides infants
to the kinds of
relevant interactions
where they might want to
learn things about people,
and their mental states, and
the words that they're using,
rather than first learning
those words through association
and then later coming to this
more abstract understanding.
So the idea is that
infants might start out
with this understanding
of what communication is
and when it's happening,
and then can sort of fill
in the rest from there,
and that this might be one
of the earlier blocks of that.
So I'll try to go fairly
quickly through the rest.
So the second insight
I wanted to bring up
that I think is
especially important
is that communication requires
this focus on intentions.
And this was really
the work of Grice
that highlighted this, and
in particular, a special type
of communicative intention.
So going back to the
example from the beginning.
When someone asks,
is there any salt,
Austin proposed that
there are these three
levels on which we can think
about this communicative
action.
And Grice was the one who
really formalized this
by talking about this
special kind of intention
that we see in the
domain of communication,
human communication
in particular, which
is the idea of speaker meaning.
And so his idea is that there's
this double-layered intention
that comes when we're
communicating with each other.
So we have a communicator
who intends the addressee
to respond in a particular way.
So here, the communicator
wants the addressee
to provide some salt.
The communicator
intends for the addressee to
recognize that the communicator
intends to have that response.
So this person not only wants
this person to pass the salt,
but wants her to
recognize that that
is what he's asking for, that
that is the request that he's
making.
And importantly,
this third point,
which is that the communicator
intends the addressee
to respond that way on the
basis of the recognition
of that intention.
And so to make this a
little more concrete,
in this case, if he
asks her for the salt,
and she passes it because
she heard him and understands
that's what he's asking
for, that's great.
But the argument is that
communication wouldn't really
be happening if,
for example, she
was wearing headphones
and listening to music,
and she hadn't really
been listening to him,
and she just happened to pick
up the salt and pass it to him.
So communication,
I mean, it would
look like a communicative
interaction.
The right kind of outcome is
still happening in response
to what he said.
But if she has no access
to the actual message,
if she doesn't produce
the response by virtue
of understanding what the
communicator is trying to say,
then communication
hasn't really occurred.
It's just sort of
a lucky accident.
So I'll skip this part.
So this is this important
kind of intention
that we see in human
communication, in which I'll
later briefly mention,
we don't really
see in animal communication
in the same sort of way.
So how do infants start to get
this idea about communication,
that it's not just
about identifying
communicative
interactions, but also
about understanding these
particular kinds of intentions?
So in the '90s,
there was this shift
in developmental psychology
to looking at word learning,
not only in terms of infants'
associations of words
in the environment, but to also,
with the work of Dare Baldwin,
to thinking about other
people's intentions
when they're using words.
And so she had these really
elegant studies where--
with this funny image--
where she pointed out
that if infants really
were learning words
through association,
then it wouldn't be
very efficient for them
because they would
make a lot of mistakes.
So for example, in
this kind of situation,
here's a dad and his baby.
The baby is looking
at this lizard.
The dad is looking
at this rooster.
And the dad says,
what a cheeky rooster.
So if you as the infant
are only learning words
on the basis of associating
what you hear with what you see,
you're going to learn that
the word rooster refers
to this thing rather
than to this thing.
And you're going
to get it wrong.
So Baldwin did a
whole host of studies
in the second year of life
where she set up situations
where infants were looking at
particular objects like here.
And then she had their parents
or an experimenter look
at a different object
and label that one
to see what infants would do.
And what she found is
that infants actually
would consult their
parent or consult
the other person for cues to
reference, to what they're
intending to label.
So if, for example,
in this situation,
the infant, when hearing
this, instead of just assuming
the word refers to what
they're looking at,
would actually look up to dad
to see what he's looking at
and then follow his line
of gaze to understand
that this is the object that
he's actually talking about.
AUDIENCE: At this age?
At this age?
ALIA MARTIN: Yeah, at this age.
Yeah.
So the idea is that infants
in the second year of life,
at least, are understanding that
understanding what someone's
referring to involves consulting
cues to their attention
and intentions rather than
just the infant's own.
And I think I'll skip this one.
There are other studies
showing this, too.
So in this one,
there's an experimenter
who puts these two
objects in a box.
The objects switch
while she's absent.
And then she looks
in one box and says--
the boxes are closed, and she
says, there's a sefo in here.
So if the infant understands
that they have to pay attention
to what the person knows about
or what the person thinks
rather than their own
knowledge to figure out
what she's labeling,
then now when she says,
can you get the sefo, the
infant should actually
pull the object out
of here, assuming
that this is the
one she's labeling,
because that's the one that
she was intending to label.
And in fact, that's what
infants do at 17 months.
In the case where the
experimenter had a false belief
about the location
of the object,
infants tend to go to
the non-referred box
more often because
they think that that's
the one that she's labeling.
But in the case where she saw
the switch happen, so now she
knows what's everywhere,
infants will just go to the box
that she's referring to figure
out the location of the object
that she's naming.
So this is all in the
second year of life, not
those younger core
knowledge ages
that Liz was talking about.
So this is evidence that
infants consult speaker cues
to intentions, but not of
this special kind of intention
that Grice was pointing out.
So I'm just going to tell
you about a couple-- well,
one of my favorite studies, I
just think that this is really
neat--
where Ellen Markman's
lab and then later
replicated by
Tomasello's lab, showed
that it seems like
children, by 30 months
and then gotten down to
18 months by Grosse et al,
actually do seem to care
about not only the effects
of communication, but
also that the effects
are produced by virtue of
the message being understood.
So you're probably
wondering why there's
a dirty sock on the screen.
So in this study, children were
presented with two objects.
So they saw, on a
table, there were
two objects that were out
of their reach, a truck
and a dirty sock.
And the idea was to elicit
children to request an object.
Now obviously, the
children are going
to request this object, which
is what the researchers had
intended in this case.
So children tended to
point at this object.
So they had children producing
their own communication,
and then the
experimenter responded
to the communication
of the infant
in one of four different ways.
So she either said, you
asked for the truck?
I'm going to give you the truck.
So she expressed
understanding of the request,
and she provided the
requested object.
In a second case, she said,
you asked for the truck?
I'm going to give you the sock.
So here, she expressed
understanding,
but refused to commit
to the request,
to give the thing the
child had asked for.
In a third case, the
experimenter said,
you asked for the sock?
I'm going to give you the truck.
So this is kind of a strange
pragmatic situation where
the experimenter actually
gave the child the object they
wanted, but she expressed a
misunderstanding of the child's
request.
And this is the
crucial case here.
So the question is,
obviously, in the case where
the experimenter
provides the thing
and expresses understanding,
children should be quite happy.
And in this situation,
they probably
shouldn't be very happy.
And what the
experimenters measured
was the amount of
times that the child
repeated the label of the
object that they had asked for.
And they also measured
other behaviors as well.
It's this situation that's
important for understanding
what kids care
about in the context
of this communicative
interaction.
So the question is, are
infants perfectly happy here
to take the truck and
not complain because they
got what they wanted?
Or do they care about the
experimenter giving them
what they wanted because
their communicated message had
the proper effect
on the addressee?
And what they find is that when
the correct object is provided,
and the experimenter does
not express understanding
of the request,
infants actually showed
the most repetitions of the
name of the requested object
in this case.
The researchers
concluded from this
that infants don't just care
about getting what they want
or using communication
as a sort of instrumental
means of getting people
to act in certain ways,
but rather as an intention to
have their messages understood
and delivered to
the other person.
So they care about the impact
of their communicative signals
on the understanding
of the addressee,
not just on the response
which is sort of like the
idea that Grice was talking
about with speaker meaning.
Similarly, when
children are responding
to other people's requests,
they also care about this.
So this is a study that
I did in graduate school.
It's sort of the opposite of the
previous study, or the inverse.
So we had an experimenter
requesting from the child
specific objects for
doing specific tasks.
This is 3-year-olds.
So she would request
something like a cup
to pour a cup of water.
The child had previous
information from playing games
with the objects with
another experimenter
that one of the cups
was perfectly fine,
and one of the cups
was broken and had
a big hole in the bottom.
And so when the experimenter
asked for a cup,
the child could either give the
cup the experimenter asked for,
which was sometimes
the perfectly good cup,
or sometimes the experimenter
requested the broken cup.
And the question was, do
children pay attention
to the fit between
the task and what
the experimenter
wanted when they're
responding to her request?
And what we found is that
children were much more
likely to give the
requested object when
the experimenter had requested
a functional object than when
she'd requested a
dysfunctional object.
So if I say, I need to
pour a cup of water,
can you give me that cup,
and the cup is broken,
children tended to go and get
a better cup instead of the one
that I had requested.
Interestingly, though, even
though children did this,
it didn't seem to be enough for
them to give the experimenter
something good that she wanted.
This is a graph of the
comments that children
made about the
function of the objects
depending on the kind of
request that was made.
And what you can see is that
when a dysfunctional object was
requested, when children
tended to provide
the functional object instead
and not respond to the request,
they were much
more likely to try
to explain their behavior
to the experimenter
and acknowledge what it was
the experiment had originally
wanted.
So it seems like children
in their own behavior,
by at least three,
which is a little older
than the other
studies, acknowledge
what the speaker meant to ask
for and explain while they're
doing something else,
even when they're not
responding to that thing.
And so, just briefly,
in the last section,
I'll talk about a third
insight about communication
that I think is really
important, which
comes from Clark, which
is that communication
is this joint action of
accumulating common ground.
And so in an example of
an adult study about this,
they showed adults pictures
like this one of New York City,
and they had people
play this game in pairs.
They had people who knew about
New York City who were experts
and who lived
there, and then they
had other people who didn't know
anything about New York City.
And they gave them
a bunch of pictures.
They told them that
their goal was to--
the person who was
the addressee had
to sort the objects in the way
that the communicator told them
to.
And so as a communicator, the
communicator had to indicate,
because they couldn't see
the pictures, which picture
the addressee should put where.
And to do this, the
communicator had
to refer to things like the
picture with the Empire State
Building in it.
And what they looked at was how
people in these interactions
accumulated shared knowledge
or common ground over time
and coordinated so their
communication could
become more efficient.
And what they found is that when
they had two New Yorkers who
were interacting
with each other,
they tended to very quickly
do the task because they could
recognize immediately,
that person's a New Yorker,
and would just say
things like, oh, it's
the one with the
Empire State Building.
Whereas when they were talking
to someone who wasn't a New
Yorker, they had to sort
of ground the conversation
by establishing these common
reference before getting
to this point.
And so they might start out
with saying things like,
oh, move the one with the
building with the pointy top.
And then eventually,
they would coordinate
on what the actual labels
for these things were.
And so Clark's idea
is that communication
is really efficient,
and we're able to do it
in the way we are
because we're thinking
about the common ground
we have with other people.
And we're able to figure out
what kind of common ground
we have with others
fairly quickly.
So if I'm interacting
with one of you,
I might assume, OK, we both know
a lot about cognitive science
already.
So I can sort of start
at a different level
than I might start with, say,
a child or someone who didn't
know anything about this area.
And so this is an important
piece of human communication.
It seems like-- and Liz
talked a little about this,
too-- it seems like
infants are starting
to show some signs
of understanding
the importance of
common ground or shared
knowledge in communication
from a really early age.
But importantly, this seems to
come in around the same time
that they recognize the
importance of speakers
facing each other
in conversation
and perhaps putting together
some of their core knowledge
domains, which is around
nine months to a year.
A lot of work in
this domain has been
done by Tomasello, who showed
that around nine months,
children were starting to do
something different than they'd
been doing earlier.
So under nine months,
children tend to--
they play with objects,
they interact with people,
but they don't seem to put
these two things together.
Whereas at nine months,
what they start doing
is paying attention, not
just to objects or to people,
but to objects and people at
the same time in the context
of a joint interaction.
So they might do things
like look at an object
and then look at mom to make
sure mom is also looking at it.
Or they might point
at things, not just
because they want the things,
as a younger child might
do, but only to share
attention with a parent
or with someone
else to point out
that they're interested
in something,
and to make sure that the
parent is looking and is
interested in it as well.
So Tomasello argues
that this ability
for engaging in joint attention,
sharing attention with someone
else, to an object or
external referent in the world
is the foundation of
linguistic communication
and also cooperation in
other very important human
activities.
And it's certainly going to be
important for an understanding
of common ground, which is
important for communication.
So there's also evidence
that around 12 months,
infants start to use
prior shared experience
to interpret communication.
I'm going to skip this, I think.
But basically, the idea--
well, I'll just go
through it quickly--
the idea is that infants will
use the activities and objects
that they've shared
with people previously
to figure out what the
person means in a new case.
So if the infant interacts with
one communicator with one toy
and with another communicator
with a different toy
separately, they will
figure out the referent
of a communicator's
ambiguous request
by thinking about
what information
they've shared in the past.
So it seems like
they're starting
to track what kinds
of knowledge is shared
and what isn't in order
to effectively communicate
with others.
OK.
So there's a lot of
other important questions
about common ground, but
I'm going to skip those now.
I just want to come back
to the question of why
infants' understanding and
children's understanding
of communication is
important for understanding
human intelligence.
So I think that one
reason is that when
you think about the insights
these philosophers had
and how they seemed
to be realized
in fairly young infants early--
children and infants
early in development,
when you look at these
abilities that humans have
and even that very young humans
have, and you compare them
to what nonhuman
animals are doing,
things look really different.
And so, just briefly,
in animal communication,
we see some of the
same kinds of features
that we see in
human communication.
So for one thing, animal
communication clearly
has a social function
in the same way
that human communication does.
So it's socially rich
in a number of ways.
I'm not going to over
specific species,
but just to gloss over it,
most animal communication
is sensitive to the
presence of an audience.
So it matters that
someone's there
to hear your communication.
For example,
species that produce
alarm calls to warn others
in their group of predators
will rarely produce these calls
if there are no other members
of their species present.
In many cases, the
sensitivity to the audience
depends on the identity
of the audience.
So for example, in some species
such as ground squirrels,
they call much more in
the presence of their kin
than when their
kin are not around
or when there are other
individuals there.
And in some cases, it seems
like there might actually even
be a sensitivity
to the knowledge
state of the audience.
So this is looking a
little more like the kind
of sophisticated communication
we see in humans.
So a wild chimpanzee,
for example,
will produce an alarm call,
will start to alarm call
more if other
chimpanzees come over
who hadn't heard the
original alarm call
or who hadn't seen the predator.
But if everyone around
has already seen it,
they'll reduce
their alarm calling.
So it seems like they tailor
it to how much information
others around them have had.
However, despite these
really interesting ways
in which animal communication
is social and complex,
it's also limited
in a number of ways
that human communication is not.
So the eliciting stimuli for
these communicative signals
tend to be fairly limited,
as do the signals themselves.
So there tends to be,
say in vervet monkeys,
one cry for a hawk and
one cry for a snake,
and they can't
realize new signals
for new kinds of
predators and situations.
As in humans, the
receivers-- or in humans,
the addressees--
acquire information
from the signals of others,
but there's no evidence
that this information tells
the receivers in animal species
anything about the mental
states of the communicator.
And additionally, the
communicator's signals
can often cause a response
in receivers that's
beneficial to the communicator.
For example, they get a
bump to indirect fitness
if they're kin run away
and survive predators.
So there can be benefits
of communication,
but there's no evidence
that the communicator
has any intention of changing
the receiver's mental state.
So there's really no evidence
of this sort of speaker meaning
or this special kind of
communicative intention
we see in humans, which is that
a communicator doesn't just
intend for the addressee to
respond in a particular way,
but intends for the audience
to respond in a particular way
by virtue of having
understood the intention
of that communication.
And so this is just a, I think,
particularly well-worded quote
from Seyfarth and
Cheney who say basically
that listeners can acquire
information from signallers,
but the signallers themselves
don't, in the human sense,
intend to provide
that information.
So the reason, really,
for this contrast
between the human
and animal cases
that I think if we want to build
a model of human communication,
we need to differentiate
it from other kinds
of communicative
models we could have.
And we also need it to
develop the types of abilities
that human infants have,
but taking into account
the resources that
infants start out with
and the developments that we see
in the first few years of life.
So it's not going to be
enough to have agents
that can influence
each other's responses
or who can understand
language, because it
seems like the recognition of
these more abstract features
of communication and its
causal effects on mental states
is actually present
fairly early on as well.
And I think just relating
this back to Liz's theory
that infants might have these
different systems for agents,
understanding agents
and their actions
on objects and then for social
beings and their interactions
with each other.
It seems like
communication and this type
of communicative
intention that we
see combines these two kinds
of things, where you have
an intention to produce
an effect on someone else,
but by virtue of them
understanding the mental states
that you have toward the world
and as well as toward them.
And maybe it's the combining
of these different domains that
helps infants put
together their possibly
human-unique, but maybe
not, communication skills.